I've never done drugs and I never will
but I have a feeling watching The Tree
of Life gives off a similar effect tree
of life is directed by Terrence Malick
very prolific director who makes about
one movie every 50 years he's a
fantastic visual director he likes to
tell his movies really through imagery
and not as much dialogue as the average
film would have to some of the plot of
this movie it's kind of like trying to
explain quantum physics to a
two-year-old it's hard it's about
creation regret laments loss family
relationships nature God it's really
encompasses life basically the film has
a lot of really beautiful visuals I mean
great use of visuals good special
effects terrence malick as a visual
director is astounding and that really
is one of the most important things a
director has to do is to be able to tell
story without having to explain it or
say it you know some characterize to
stand for this grandeur right now the
characters are doing this this movie's
gotten all different types of responses
some people are calling it a masterpiece
some people are calling it the best film
of the year some people are saying what
in the world that I just watch I'm kind
of somewhere in the middle I think it's
so difficult for the average viewer to
relate to and understand with all of the
metaphorical imagery and everything
that's kind of a flaw for the movie
there are really good performances here
the kids are all good even though I'm
sure they had no idea what in the world
is going on Brad Pitt is great as well
as Jessica Chastain Sean Penn doesn't
really have much to do in this film to
be honest in fact I'm not even sure if
you actually ever see him open his mouth
and talk the film is told largely
through imagery and poetic dialogue the
first half of the film I really enjoyed
there's some really great sequences and
it really came off as an incredibly good
animal documentary and then the last
half of the film just got kind of slow
for me the way it was filled with the
way I look is still so original the
movie is like two hours and 20 minutes
long there isn't
of a story in this film for me to feel
engaged by I need a good story and I
know that this film is trying to
basically tell the story of life in
general and all of the ups and downs of
it but it's just so difficult to grasp
at times however I cannot in any way
fault the obvious filmmaking talent on
display here and the talent of all the
actors as well and for that reason this
is definitely a movie that you would
probably want to experience at least
once if you are a film affectionate like
I am then you will definitely find
things to enjoy in this film as I did as
well it's just that I feel that the
average moviegoer is just going to kind
of be sitting there like what in the
world am i watching it's kind of like a
modern-day 2001 a Space Odyssey which is
a classic film and also told and
directed beautifully but at the same
time it's just not the kind of movie
that I'm going to want to sit down and
watch again towards the last half I just
felt a major disconnect so much of it is
so difficult to understand I don't need
to be told all the answers and I don't
need everything to be explained to me I
want to be able to grasp the message and
I had a hard time grasping the message
of The Tree of Life so I'm going to give
it three out of four stars
Oh